speak about how you convince people once
they've chosen the path of violence to
renounce it and to find some sort of
peaceful solution so you mentioned
gaining the respect to people because
you've gone to talk to them but past
that what sort of arguments that you
make to convince people that there was
actually a more peaceful way and that
that way it would be better especially
considering the fact perhaps that
violence initially might have proven
successful to the IRA and getting
worldwide attention or not could I just
say something here because I think two
people say what was the turning point
the turning point of our situation was
reality reality there were two realities
one was on the part of the republican
movement that they were not going to
create a united Ireland their aspiration
could not be fulfilled through violence
that had become very clear and the
second one of how correct Prime Minister
was they acknowledged Minh tanned the
reality on the part of the British
government that this could not be this
was not a winnable war yeah both sides
both sides gave the conclusion it
couldn't be one militarily but I think
and I think that was incredibly
important but I think Rachel the answer
to your question is that when you get
into dialogue you can do two things you
can first of all explain that there is
another way forward you know just the
mere fact of dialogue is not enough you
have to explain there is another way
forward but the second thing you can do
and this is really really important is
you can explain that the other side is
maybe not like they think the other side
is you know what happens in these
situations this is where religion
because it becomes that sort of dominant
culture plays such a major impact
is that people end up feeling and
believing that they are if the pain is
that the pain is all on their side you
know the thing that I find most
difficult in the israeli-palestinian
issue now is you will talk to Israelis
who have seen the effects of suicide
bombs and Tel Aviv of Jerusalem or the
Rockets coming into Ashkelon from Gaza
and they can see that they find it
really hard to see what it's like to be
a Palestinian Gaza when the retaliatory
attack happens and an innocent families
killed they it's and part of the
dialogue what you do when you you get
into dialogue is you can sensitize the
put that person to the other person's
feeling and that is because I think what
happens in these situations is that they
people really do believe that the other
people have evil intent towards them
rather than are also victims of the
conflict I mean that their perpetrators
are not victims